- Do you think for teaching and in general
thinking about new concepts,
do you think it's better
to plug in the numbers,
or to think more abstractly?
So, looking at theorems
and proving the theorems
or actually building up a
basic intuition of the theorem
or the method, the approach,
and then just plugging in
numbers and seeing it work?
- Well, certainly many of
us like to see examples.
We understand.
It might be a pretty
abstract sounding example
like a three dimensional rotation.
How are you gonna
understand a rotation in 3D?
Or in 10D?
And then some of us like
to keep going with it
to the point where you got numbers.
Where you got 10 angles,
10 axes, 10 angles.
The great mathematicians probably,
I don't know if they do that,
'cause for them an example would be
a highly abstract thing to the rest of us.
- Right.
But nevertheless, working
with in the space of examples.
- Yeah, examples.
- It seems to.
- Examples of structure.
- Our brains seem to connect with that.
- Yeah, yeah.